in A Song of Ice and Fire award is
described as someone who can enter the
mind of a wolf less specific terms would
be be sling or skin-changer these terms
refer to someone who can enter the mind
of animals and do their bidding through
them the ability to skin change is well
known amongst the free folk beyond the
wall and the power set to go back
thousands of years in our story it is
known that all the star children have
the ability to skin change according to
Vera mere six skins of the free folk
skin changes can sense each other and
know immediately whether or not they are
in the presence of one with the gift
upon seeing Jon Snow
bear Amir immediately recognizes Jon's
ability as a wall suggesting even that
Jon may be even more powerful than their
Amir himself Arya Stark unlike Jon Snow
has demonstrated herself to be more than
simply award during her training of the
faceless men Arya Stark is blinded as a
punishment for the killing of Darion the
singer it is in this moment that her
gift as a skin-changer truly activates
she uses her power to see through the
eyes of stray cat even though she does
not realize that she is doing it Arya
also transfers her consciousness to her
dire wolf Nymeria when she sleeps
although she believed that what she sees
are merely dreams bran stark it's
certainly the most powerful not least
our children he has a gift of skin
changing it's so powerful and he can
transfer his mind even into human hosts
a task in which they ultra powerful very
mere six skins
feyo's act in addition to being a very
powerful skin ginger bran is also a
green seer he has the ability to reach
through the veil of time and see beyond
the little is known of the extent of it
Rickon Stark seems possessed some
greenseer ability as well after Ned is
killed he and his brother bran both
dream of their father dead inside the
crypts of Winterfell
father is not here yes he is I saw him
tears glistened on written faith I saw
him last night
in your dream Rickon nodded you leave
him you leave him be he's coming home
now like he promised he's coming home
less is known to what extent Sansa and
Robb Stark possess these abilities as
well but it has been confirmed by author
george RR martin that all the stark
children indeed do possess some
skin-changer ability why is the ability
to skin change so prevalent amongst the
stark children the obvious answer is
genetics the Starks have wild in blood
and as I mentioned earlier skin changing
is a well-known gift beyond the wall but
even the wildlings weren't the first to
possess these abilities the first skin
changers and green seers were the
children of the forest it is said that
during the hundreds of years of conflict
between the children of the forest and
men lacking in physical strength and
sophisticated weaponry
the children would used their power to
employ animals to fight for them the
wise men of the children were called
green seers they too had the power to
see beyond so what the children of the
forest were the original users of the
power and how did mankind come to
possess it well it may be possible that
the children of the forest taught these
abilities to mankind but if that was the
case then why does it now appear to be
genetic I think the more likely answer
must be that the children did not teach
these gifts to men they simply bred with
men passing down these abilities the
Starks are one of the oldest houses in
Westeros descended from the first men if
the blood of the children may exist in
any bloodline then the Starks would be
the perfect candidate but there is
another mystery to be answered if the
skin-changer ability is genetic then why
is it that no other Starks are mentioned
to have this ability
if this gift was truly in the start
bloodline would it not have manifested
in many Starks throughout the centuries
why is there no evidence of other Starks
with these powers perhaps it is because
these Starks have something that few
others have had
real dire roles upon discovering the
wolves in a game of groans the group is
confused as to why the animals are there
for dire wolves haven't been seen south
of the wall in thousands of years in
regards to the animals that the children
of the forest used to fight for them
dire wolves are mentioned very first in
the world of Ice and Fire
the term warg itself is the only term in
the books that refers to a specific
animal being skinned changed a wolf is
there something inherently special about
the dire wolves that awakens a latent
skin-changer ability upon discovery of
the first five wolves Jon Snow
inexplicably turns back to find a sixth
war which has separated away from the
other five almost as if he could already
sense its presence but there are other
beasts mentioned specifically that the
children had control over snow bears and
mammoths which are found only north of
the wall lions which were hunted to
extinction by the first men serpents
which could never survive in the north
of Westeros due to the cold and eagles
these animals are all either extinct or
out of reach for most Starks born after
the raising of the wall if it requires
one of these animal familiars of sorts
to awaken skin-changer abilities then it
seems to explain why there are no other
Starks that have demonstrated these
gifts and it also seems important to
note that each of the Starks were
children at the point where they came
into contact with their dire wolves for
the first time the oldest being Robb
Stark at age 14
the stark magic seems to be latent
genetic ability present within the stark
bloodline that was awakened by the
presence of these dire wolves knowing
that a Song of Ice and Fire is rarely
ever what it appears to be on the
surface it is hard to accept that these
dire wolves showing up when they did was
a coincidence
perhaps they were sent by bloodraven who
saw the necessity of it in his grand
scheme or perhaps even stranger more
powerful forces were behind the
appearance of these wolves
the answer is unclear but what is clear
is that the start children each possess
power of their own that once honed could
be used in ways that no one has foreseen
[Music]